avant il ya seulement quelques années
c'était encore pensé qu' il y a aucune
lui sur la glace par étudiant il a
consacré ses trois milieux de vie pour
tellement plein d'organismes ce qu'on
soupçonne pas et après c'est le même qui
apprennent à petit de vitry creux de la
vague il y a surtout le zooplancton et
sont en train de reproduire
ils sont énormes la super intéressant le
mois
termonde qui est inconnu donc c'est très
dur de prédire ce qui va se passer a dit
réchauffement climatique
une entrée une paire de couverts de
glace on peut pas vraiment prédire ce
qui va se passer si on sait qu aux
quelque 36
[Musique]
parce que c'est seulement après avoir
commencé à étudier biologique que
j'avais mon tombé en amour avec l'hiver
j'ai vu comment l'hiver au québec est
magnifique
kal penn ne me suis pas certaine qu'ils
nous restent des dizaines et des
dizaines d'années de beaux l'hiver au
québec qui sans besoin de voir à quel
point on est plus en plus d'événements
puni pendant l'hiver
en même temps je suis choix à terme en
plus là il faut voir plus steve pouvoir
qu'est ce qu'on peut changer mais c'est
ce que si on peut continuer à avoir de
la neige le plus longtemps possible ça
ça va me rendre heureuse on va faire ça
c'est plus fois à la surface est plus
chaud au fond toute la chaleur qui
étaient stockés d'un dans le lac en été
alors si les fonds vont normalement
c'est foncier le serbe sort beaucoup de
chaleur et en hiver ça dégage déjà leurs
reflets pour pour le zooplancton
donc c'est vraiment très très faim et ce
pour attraper les petits organismes
on voit déjà ici commence et rouge
il y en a deux organismes oui le voit
mais c'est que nous au plancton faut il
stocke de nrj en termes de grave juste à
voir les verts alors il devient
extrêmement obèses
ça explique pourquoi ils sont capables
de survie si bien l'hiver est aussi
paraître introduisent en hiver milieux
divers terrains échantillons ou si la
glace pour comparer la composition de la
classe et la composition l'eau donc on
perd cela lasse puis on récolte ses 42
lâche devoir rapporte sur laboratoire
finalement on a mesuré une quantité
vraiment surprenante de matières
organiques qui venaient principalement
de l'extérieur du lac soit des plans des
feuilles du bassin versant qui sont
apportées puis intégré dans la glace
puis qui reste selon yvan puis au
printemps qui a aussi libéré ça peut
faire un boost d'énergie pour tout le
système le pont est trouvé plein de
plantes carbone et des bactéries
vraiment de faire une substance dans la
tasse
[Musique]
donc ils venant avec les changements
climatiques l'épaisseur de la glace plus
la durée dans la saison sur les lacs et
les rivières à travers le monde diminue
de façon considérable
c'est quoi les impacts la perte de glace
pour savoir qu'est ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur
si la joue un rôle important dans le
système dans l'année elle a perdu la
place doit avoir un effet
[Musique]